We are teaching people how to pray
>> and every time they pray you get the
share in that reward and when they teach
their children
>> and their children's children
>> the reward continues every
recitation for just £100
>> you can help teach 20 to 60 people like
me learn how to pray salah donate today
brothers and sisters and dear friends
I'm here with brother Lukar
How you doing?
>> Alhamdulillah.
>> Mashallah. And your wife, sister.
>> Fatima. You are an Italian revert and
you're a born Muslim
>> from Ghana.
>> Alhamdulillah.
>> Beautiful. Alhamdulillah. Amazing couple
came here with their children. Brothers
and sisters, what we have on the table
as you can see is our guided salah mat.
Salah prog guided mat that comes with
the woodoo guide with a packaging. At
the back it tells you to download the
salah pro app inshallah which is for
free. All of our service for free
inshallah. Sister Fatima has an amazing
story. You came to Islam when sister?
>> On 2018. So almost eight years ago.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah.
>> About eight years ago. Yeah. Okay.
Perfect. Inshallah. So how did you learn
how to pray salah?
>> So unfortunately I didn't have
opportunity to use this one first.
>> But um I started to learn um by
following um video on YouTube. So I
would um place for example like uh I
would place uh my normal pray mat on the
floor and then place my phone or my
tablet um in front of me. Uh so
depending on on the prayer time um I
opened like I don't know a video
specific video like faja or zur or
depended that the prayer time and uh yes
so I started to to listen repeating all
the words like that and then obviously
step by step after a few months I
started to read from transliteration.
It's a literation uh for to correct my
words and then um yeah after few years I
now I use this one so it doesn't matter
for my opinion I know maybe most of the
the Muslim converted to Islam few years
ago or or high years ago and maybe you
think okay maybe I don't need no you
still need for my opinion because anyway
you are not Arabic so new language for
you and you need to um obviously you
need to all the time try to remember the
the the correct words um for my opinion
like I say uh all the time this carpet
make you um stay in focus um
as well.
>> Yeah. So
>> so that's interesting. So you've said
that you learned salah a long time ago
but you still use this mat today
>> for for for and focus. Yes,
>> that's profound, guys. And this mat is,
as you can see, subhan Allah, to teach
thousands to learn how to pray salah.
Brothers and sisters, this was
specifically sponsored by brother Omar.
As you can see, his name is written
here. He says, "This guide, my guided
mat was sponsored by Omar. Please
remember them in your prayers."
Alhamdulillah. And brothers and sisters,
as you can see, not not only that, she's
now still using it till this day. Subhan
Allah. Your father your father accepted
Islam.
>> Yes. Alhamdulillah.
>> And subhan Allah, tell us you you said
that you gave this mat as a gift to him.
>> Yes. So
uh he become Muslim around August I
think he a shadow with me in video call
before and then after few weeks in the
mosque in Palmo um with the imam uh so I
started everything with him by video
call because I'm I'm in London is in
Palmo so I try to teach him how to do
the voodoo uh you know all the base um
he was in the it was struggle with some
bad situation. So I try to introduce
Islam for to be uh for to feel better
you know in fact if he felt better
alhamdulillah with Islam and uh he pray
every day uh he use this math every time
I ask him uh did you use the m the math
he say yes I use this math I feel
comfortable
it easy for me to read and to be honest
as I say all the time um this play
pretty much you can carry it uh um
everywhere anytime because it's light.
So you can put in the bag, you can put
in the pocket, you can I don't know you
can bring in the mosque at work. So
yeah, please donate. Please order this
mask.
>> So how much did you pay for the mat? Was
it £100?
>> Uh did you pay £50? How much did you pay
for it?
>> I don't remember.
>> No, dude.
>> Yeah. No, I was thinking about it. I did
a donate, but I think
>> No, no, no, no. Not not donate. How much
did you buy the mat for?
>> No, no, it was zero.
>> Are you sure? Are you sure you're saying
that because we we paid you to say that?
Or is it cuz it's free?
>> No.
>> No, it was free. It was free. But
doesn't the language vary
was asking how much you donated? It's
for free.
>> No, it was the donation like
>> Yeah, it's for free.
>> Yeah, this is freeact.
>> Yes, exactly. So, subh. The mat is for
free. The onetoone salah instructors we
have is for free. The app is for free.
The hubs are for free. Brothers and
sisters, the reason it's for free is
because of your donations that we can
serve people like sister Fatima, her
children generations to come in and her
father inshallah as a born Muslim. Do
you not think because it's easy for
someone who's born your family teaches
you the importance? Why is it so
important for us to help this? Because
this project is not just for reverbs. We
also teach Muslims who don't know how to
pray salah. So what why do you think
it's important for people to have these
resources would you say?
>> Um first of all I'll say salalam
alalaykum to to everyone watching. Um
well um I have just few things to say.
Um, so to be honest with you, um, born a
Muslim for me obviously was really,
really easy because, um, I got to learn
everything when I was when I was
younger. But then, um, growing up,
obviously, um, when I first met my wife,
um, you know, I have to teach her
because I didn't know there's anything
like this. You know, would have been
much easier for me back then. But then I
have to teach her, you know, everything.
But then when her dad obviously tried to
um to to begin to learn about Islam,
okay, that's where I understood the
important of this map. Okay, so because
we live in London and then he lives in
Italy, okay, so it made it made our life
very very easy. So because she has to um
take this map to him and then he has to
just read it, follow the instructions.
So for example, that's just an example
of her dad. Okay, imagine there are
millions and other, you know, thousands
of people, you know, revet that might be
struggling, you know, I'm talking
specifically for the revet that might be
struggling obviously to to to to to
pray, you know, how to pray, how to do
it correctly. Um, but there is nothing
like this, you know. So, this is there
for for people like them, you know. So,
it's really really uh an amazing thing,
okay? And especially being for free
makes it even much much better. Okay. Um
let just give you just a small um
scenario. Okay. So I have a friend um in
America. Okay.
>> Um and he has another friend. So I get
to meet them last year and um so my
friend friend is now a rever. He lives
in a different state in America
>> and um it's so it's so difficult for him
because he's just by himself. So
actually because of this thing is for
free and now obviously um I get to know
this.
>> I would really really recommend to get
one and I can send it to him because
he's just by himself and it's hard. Have
>> you got one or should we give you one
now?
>> Um yeah maybe one now. Yeah. Yeah. 100%
on on he's struggling to to to know to
pray and stuff like that. So I would say
um my personal opinion um is really
really a nice thing and um you know all
the instructions makes it so easy. Um,
and I'll recommend to some of the
Muslims as well because we think we know
everything. We know how to pray. Um,
>> and and and and and this obviously
simplifies a lot of things. So, um,
>> and not only that, not only that, if you
want videos, we got the Salah Pro app.
You can watch videos on how to pray, how
to do woo, how to do, and the mat is for
free sisters. You can even attend our
Salah hubs. We work with mosques across
uh the country and in Europe where you
can attend weekly lessons that sponsored
by Salah. May Allah bless you. Uh in
some good news
>> Italian sample say you're lucky. Hey so
we've got so so we sent three and a half
thousand Italian to Italy in Italian in
to one of our salah hubs there which are
distributing across Italy that would
just managed to hunt down and find
Italian. So that's for your friend
>> in we need one more for his friend in
America.
>> Brother sisters support the project
inshallah today we're trying to hit the
200,000 mark. If there is someone
watching this who has the means of
giving5 £10,000, you've seen the proof
in the pudding. Go to the link and find
more information where your money is
going to be going and where it has been
gone. So guys, till next time
from our Ghanaian brother and revert
sister Italian Fatima and my Italian
name is Lorenzo. [laughter]
>> Inshallah. Yes. He's Antonio.
>> Antonio.
>> That's Fabio. And this one is uh
>> Raandroandama [laughter]
everybody brothers and sisters with the
da our brothers here in Mumford and
we're sharing a beautiful message of
Islam for anybody who's interested and
we're also distributing these uh prayer
mats and this box mashallah has been
kindly sponsored uh and funded by
Muhammad Khan and may Allah accept his
uh his efforts his charity it's a great
initiative in order to help people learn
how to pray. Um, and then in addition,
you can also organize a one-on-one
instruction uh session with a brother or
sister to teach you directly how to
pray. May Allah accept it from
everybody. After that,